QUESTION STOCKING THE
BROWARD COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
WHO IS SCOTT ISRAEL AND WHAT DO
WE REALLY KNOW ABOUT HIM?
HE IS A COLORFUL, BRASH,
OUTSPOKEN BROWARD COUNTY SHERIFF
WHO HAS BEEN SPEAKING FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT SINCE THE
VALENTINE'S DAY MASSACRE AT
STONEMAN DOUGLAS HIGH SCHOOL.
JUST EIGHT DAYS AFTER THE
SHOOTING, BEFORE HIS DEPARTMENT
HAD EVEN CONCLUDED ITS OWN
INVESTIGATION, SHERIFF ISRAEL
FOUND TIME TO JOIN A CNN TOWN
HALL WHERE HE DECIDED TO JOIN
FORCES WITH THE PRO-GUN-CONTROL
LOBBY.
>> 18-YEAR-OLDS SHOULD NEVER
HAVE A RIFLE.
AN 18-YEAR-OLD KID SHOULD NOT
18-YEAR-OLD KIDS, THEY'RE NOT
ADULTS YET.
THEY'RE IN HIGH SCHOOL.
THESE KIDS SHOULD NOT HAVE A
RIFLE.
AUTOMATIC RIFLE SHOULD BE
OUTLAWED, AND ANYBODY WHO SAYS
DIFFERENT, I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
OTHER PEOPLE, WE ARE --
>> Laura: HE IS SUCH A
BLOWHARD.
THE SHERIFF HAD TO KNOW THAT THE
AUTOMATIC WEAPONS HE REFERENCED
IN THAT SOUND BITE WERE BANNED
BY THE FEDS YEARS AGO AND THAT
THE NRA IT DOES NOT ADVOCATE FOR
LEGALIZING THEM, SHERIFF.
IT GOT TO KNOW THAT OR YOU
SHOULD BE IN THAT JOB AT ALL.
BUT IT SOUNDED GOOD IN FRONT OF
THAT CROWD AND IT BROUGHT THE
AUDIENCE TO ITS FEET.
AND JUST A FEW DAYS LATER,
ISRAEL REVEALED THE EXISTENCE OF
VIDEOTAPE AND A LITTLE PIECE OF
INFORMATION THAT I THOUGHT WAS
KIND OF IMPORTANT.
>> WELL, WHAT I SAW WAS A DEPUTY
ARRIVED AT THE WEST SIDE OF
BUILDING 12, TAKE UP A POSITION,
AND HE NEVER WENT IN.
>> Laura: WELL, ONCE THAT
CHOICE PIECE OF INFORMATION
BECAME PUBLIC AND MORE BEGAN TO
TRICKLE OUT ABOUT THE
DEPARTMENT'S HANDLING OF AT
LEAST 23 CALLS TO THE CRUZ
RESIDENCE, RICK SCOTT AND 20
OTHERS ASKED FOR
SHERIFF ISRAEL'S RESIGNATION.
HE WAS ASKED ABOUT THE CALL FOR
HIM TO STEP DOWN.
>> I HAVE GIVEN AMAZING
LEADERSHIP TO THIS DEPARTMENT.
YES.
THERE IS A LOT OF THINGS WE HAVE
DONE THROUGHOUT THIS.
YOU DON'T MEASURE A PERSON'S
LEADERSHIP --
SPOON YOU DON'T MEASURE A
PERSON'S LEADERSHIP?
YES, WE DO MEASURE A PERSON'S
LEADERSHIP.
POLICE IN BROWARD COUNTY WHERE
BODY CAMERAS, AND WE KNOW THERE
WAS SECURITY CAMERA FOOTAGE
BECAUSE AUTHORITIES REFUSED TO
PUBLICLY RELEASE IT.
>> WE ARE NOT GOING TO DISCLOSE
THE VIDEO AT THIS TIME, AND WE
MAY NEVER DISCLOSE THE VIDEO
DEPENDING ON THE PROSECUTION AND
THE CRIMINAL CASE.
>> Laura: MM.
THAT SEEMS REALLY BOGUS TO ME
AND REALLY WEIRD.
WE MAY NEVER RELEASE THE VIDEO?
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN VIDEO OF THE
KIDS LEAVING THE BUILDING.
RELEASE THE VIDEO THAT WOULD
ARGUABLY BE OF THE MOST INTEREST
TO THE PUBLIC?
NOW, THE VIDEO REVEALS HOW
OFFICER PETERSON AND OTHER
DEPUTIES RESPONDED TO THIS
ACTIVE SHOOTER SITUATION.
IT'S KIND OF IMPORTANT, DON'T
YOU THINK?
NOW, COULD IT BE THAT THE VIDEO
WOULD BE PERHAPS HIGHLY DAMAGING
TO THE SHERIFF 'S OFFICE AND
PERHAPS TO THE SHERIFF
PERSONALLY?
AND BACK TO HIS APPEARANCE AT
THAT CNN TOWN HALL MEETING, WHY
ON EARTH DID HE CHOOSE TO GO ON
TV TO MAKE HIMSELF THE CENTER OF
HIS HEATED POLITICAL DEBATE?
IS THAT REALLY HIS ROLE?
THEN HE WENT ON TELEVISION THE
NEXT DAY, JUST YESTERDAY, TO
PRAISE HIS OWN LEADERSHIP AS
AMAZING.
JUST BIZARRE.
BY THE WAY, THIS WASN'T THE
FIRST TIME SHERIFF ISRAEL
IGNITED CONTROVERSY FOR MAKING
HIMSELF THE MAIN ATTRACTION.
BACK IN SEPTEMBER OF 2015, HE
TOOK MAJOR HEAT FOR PUTTING HIS
BIG FACE ON A FIVE TAXPAYER
FINANCED BROWARD COUNTY CARDS.
THEY WERE CALLED JOKINGLY
"ISRAEL-MOBILES, AND TOO MANY
PEOPLE, THEY'RE MORE ABOUT
POLITICS AND POLICING.
THEY WERE TO BE ASSIGNED TO
MEMBERS OF ISRAEL'S COMMUNITY
OUTREACH TEAM, WHICH ITSELF HAD
BEEN STAFFED BY, IT LOOKS LIKE
JUST THE SHERIFF CAMPAIGN
SUPPORTERS.
HE GOT HAMMERED FOR THAT AS
WELL.
JUST A FEW HOURS AGO,
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" RECEIVED
COPIES OF INTERNAL, NO MAKE
EMAILS FROM A SOURCE CLOSE TO
THE BROWARD SHERIFF'S OFFICE
WHICH HAS SINCE BEEN CONFIRMED
BY A SECOND SOURCE THIS EVENING
BY ONE OF OUR PRODUCERS.
NOW, IT URGES ALL STAFF MEMBERS
TO VIGOROUSLY SUPPORT SHERIFF
SHERIFF ISRAEL, AT THE MOMENT WE
FIND OUR AGENCY UP AGAINST A
FLURRY OF MEDIA ALLEGATIONS AND
A PERSONAL ATTACK AGAINST OUR
SHERIFF, SHERIFF ISRAEL,
SHERIFF ISRAEL STOOD WITH US AND
WE MUST STAND WITH HIM.
IT IS IMPORTANT THEY KNOW WE
STAND AS ONE.
MM.
THE FOCUS SHOULD BE ON GETTING
TO THE BOTTOM OF WHAT HAPPENED
LEADING UP TO THE SHOOTING, NOT
SOME CYA DEAL FOR THE SHERIFF.
WE NEED TO KNOW ABOUT THE
ACTIONS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT ON
THE DAY OF THE SHOOTING.
IT SHOULDN'T BE ABOUT SAVING
SHERIFF ISRAEL'S JOB BECAUSE
THAT WOULD BE REALLY PATHETIC.
NOW, THE GOVERNOR YESTERDAY
ANNOUNCED THAT FLORIDA'S
DEPARTMENT OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
WILL INVESTIGATE
BROWARD COUNTY'S RESPONSE TO THE
SHOOTING, WITH WHICH
SHERIFF ISRAEL SAID HE WOULD
COOPERATE FULLY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND WITH THE
GOVERNORS OF THE WHITE HOUSE AND
THEY DISCUSSED SCHOOL SAFETY IN
THE AFTERMATH OF THE PARKLAND
SHOOTING.
>> WE HAVE TO TAKE STEPS TO
HARDEN OUR SCHOOL SO THEY ARE
LESS VULNERABLE TO ATTACKS.
THIS INCLUDES ALLOWING WELL
TRAINED AND CERTIFIED SCHOOL
PERSONNEL TO CARRY CARRY
CONCEALED FIREARMS.
AT SOME POINT, YOU NEED VOLUME.
>> Laura: BEFORE THIS
ADMINISTRATION, IN THE END,
EMBARKS ON SOME LEGISLATIVE
RESPONSE TO THE SHOOTING, THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD REQUEST THAT
ATTORNEY GENERAL SESSIONS OPEN
HIS OWN FEDERAL INVESTIGATION
INTO THIS ENTIRE MATTER.
AND THAT MEANS NOT ONLY EXAMINE
WHAT HAPPENED ON THAT HORRIBLE
DAY BUT ALSO THE FBI'S FAILURE
TO FOLLOW UP ON CRITICAL TIPS,
THE SCHOOL'S INTERNAL
DISCIPLINARY RECORD, AND
BROWARD'S OWN INTERACTIONS WITH
CRUZ AND THE FAMILY.
NO LAW-ABIDING AMERICAN ABOUT
SNOW MYS SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHTS
SHOULD BE DILUTED OR COMPROMISED
BEFORE WE KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
HAPPENED FROM THE MOMENT
THAT FIRST DISTRESS CALL CAME
INTO THE BROWARD SHERIFF'S
OFFICE, AND SHERIFF ISRAEL
SHOULD SPEND A LOT LESS TIME
PATTING HIMSELF ON THE BACK AND